how do you start working for nasa do you  know what it's interesting when i was  six years old i went to the jet  propulsion laboratory  and there i was there for a  field trip it was a school field trip  and i saw the rocket engines and i saw  the pictures of the men on the wall who  were launching rockets and i looked at  the pictures and i told myself i want to  be just like the men and i didn't  realize how challenging it was going to  be as a woman because typically women  are not in the rocket science world and  being a woman of color people don't know  that one out of 31 000 african-american  women  or women of color  get a phd in the mathematics or  scientist science or or become a rocket  scientist and so when i was six years  old i was looking at these engines and  jet propulsion laboratories mission  control and i told myself i wanted to be  just like those men  [Music]  baby you're my pearl